ganz anderes thema und eine schlimme
entwicklung immer mehr menschen in
deutschland haben angst sich demnächst
ihre wohnung nicht mehr leisten zu
können
jetzt aber die richtig schlechte
nachrichten nicht nur in großen nein
auch in kleinen und mittleren städten
ziehen die mieten neuerdings brutal anja
in magdeburg zb in magdeburg zum
beispiel zahlt man im schnitt jetzt 34
prozent seines einkommens für miete dann
wohl man in magdeburg mehr als beispiel
ich habe das gefühl unsere gruppe hat
die soziale sprengkraft des themas bauen
und wohnen noch gar nicht so richtig
realisiert woran liegt das denn das ist
der zuständige bauminister horst
seehofer ach du scheiße kann er nicht
nur obergrenze für mieten einführen nur
so als idee alles was denen einfällt ist
sie wollen die mietpreis bleiben sie um
ein paar jahre verlängern heißt es die
mietpreis bremse die aber nur in manchen
vierteln und städten den preisanstieg
minimal abmildert und ob kommt demnächst
die neue grundsteuer die egal was man
erzählt natürlich auf mieten
durchschlagen wird
wenn das so weiter geht dann wollen wir
bald alle wie in china
morgens und abends wenn viel
berufsverkehr da oben ist kann es etwas
laut sein sagt er wo der direkt unter
der straße wohnt und auch das sparen
platz die linie 2 der stadtbahn fährt
durch den sechsten bis achten stock des
wohnhauses
nächster halt gästeklo meine damen
jetzt mal zurück zu deutschland die
groko tut immer noch viel zu wenig gegen
wohnungsnot das ist das thema unserer
zeit sicher es gibt das so genannte
baukindergeld wissen sie 1200 euro
staatlicher zuschuss pro kind und jahr
also die legendäre aktionen vögel dich
ins eigenheim ist bekannt aber die ist
ein flop denn sie führt kaum zu
neubauten fast 90 prozent der anträge
wurden für bestandsimmobilien gestellt
sonst noch irgendwelche tollen groko
ideen der bausparer muss einfach wieder
sexy werden ja
alte regel die worte sexy und bausparer
können nicht im selben satz vorkommen
ist gar
ja
entschuldigung aber diese staatliche
prämie hier die treibt in einem ohnehin
überhitzte baumarkt die baupreise noch
weiter nach oben insgesamt sind die
baukosten bei uns in deutschland seit
2005 um 33 prozent gestiegen im selben
zeitraum in den niederlanden nur um 6%
es fakt ja dabei dabei sind die häuser
dabei sind die häuser da nicht
schlechter die niederländer das ist der
trick benutzen aber für sozialwohnungen
genormte fertigteile die du also in
masse und damit viel billiger
produzieren kannst könnten wir
theoretisch auch machen geht aber nicht
weil bei uns jedes bissige bundesland
seine eigene bauordnung hat die 16
bauminister der einzelnen bundesländer
sie müssten sich auf ein einziges großes
baugesetz für ganz deutschland einigen
das weiß eigentlich jeder nur dann
bräuchte man eben auch diese 16
bauminister nicht mehr
und das kann wirklich keiner wollen
schauen sie in dieser bauminister augen
und sagen sie denen dass sie bald
arbeitslos
das
ja
an ihm kommt
wenn die 16 bauminister traurig sind
dann lassen wir es wie es ist
bauen ist halt nichts für weicheier
fuchs freunde wie seit jahren seit
jahren weiß man übrigens im politischen
berlin dass wir in deutschland immer
noch zu langsam und viel zu teuer bauen
deswegen haben wir doch seit 2014 die
sogenannte bau kostensenkungs kommission
was macht ihr eigentlich aus der bau
kostensenkungs kommission entstand keine
änderung im baugesetz nur eine neue
arbeitsgruppe die arbeitsgruppe
standards im bauwesen ihr ergebnis ein
neuer ausschuss der sonder
präsidialausschuss bauen und gebäude und
dessen ergebnis war der ständige
präsidialausschuss bauwerke tja dann
geht ja alles seinen geregelten gang
würde ich sagen
ausschüsse und bürokratie da macht uns
keiner was vor das ist sie nämlich die
berühmte deutsche leitkultur um die uns
die welt beneidet wenn wir es nicht mal
schaffen freundin die bauvorschriften
der bundesländer zu vereinheitlichen
dann müsste man eigentlich schon die
kleinste in deutschland form bauen
warnen machen wir auch hol dir jetzt den
lego bausatz eigenheim
der weg zur traumimmobilie endlich
realistisch nachgespielt nicht einfach
bauen bist du blöd das hier ist
deutschland ließ so lange über
fahrradstellplätze barrierefreiheit und
beschissener abstandsflächen bist du
keinen bock mehr hass jemals wieder
irgendwas zu bauen
siehste geht doch
finger weg nicht damit spielen jetzt
kaufst du dir erstmal das erweiterungs
energetische dämmung der gesetzgeber
zwingt dich deine wurde komplett in
styropor einzupacken aber vorsicht damit
nicht schimmelt musst du dann noch
hochgiftige biozide drauf pinseln und
zack geht's in die notaufnahme
die eigenen vier wände man ist das ne
scheiß idee